there's a great woman she's gone viral
now she was speaking
at a government proceeding
about the mask itself because there are
two views on the masks the one
there's the the left-wing argument on
the masks which some
squish republicans went along with and
then there's the
proper understanding of the masks what
the left said was the masks they're
look just common sense we're all gonna
muzzle ourselves we're all gonna for the
first time ever
wear this ridiculous face covering and
that's gonna ease us all back into
society it's going to make us all feel
better
when you walk around and you see
everyone covering up their face like a
bunch of banditos
like like secular burqas does that make
you feel better does that let your
anxiety go down no of course not
the proper view of the masks was this
was always a symbol
to keep everybody agitated to keep
everybody
even more ready to give away their power
to the government and to the experts in
particular because they
they just have this visual cue oh gosh
we've never been
in this situation before i've never seen
this before this pandemic must be super
duper serious
wear the mask sheep god give the power
away to dr fauci everybody
right and and so the psychological
effect of that
is really insane a woman has gone viral
for pointing this out and demanding
take off the masks this is not march
2020 anymore
we have three vaccines every adult in
the state of georgia that wants that
vaccine is eligible to get it
right now and every one of us knows that
young children are not affected by this
virus
they're not and that's a blessing but as
the adults what have we done with that
blessing
we've shoved it to the side and we've
said we don't care you're still going to
wear a mask on your face
every day five and six-year-olds you
still can't play together on the
playground like normal children seven
and eight-year-olds
we don't care we're still going to force
you to carry a burden that was never
yours to carry shame on us
it's april 15 2021
and it's time take these masks off
of my child we chose you to make
decisions that would be in our
children's best interest
and forcing five six seven eight and
nine-year-old little children
to cover their noses and their mouths
where they breathe
for seven hours a day every day for the
last nine months for a virus that you
know
doesn't affect them that is not in their
best
interest and this has to stop
preach sister preach love it
what can i vote for that woman for what
what can she run for where i can vote
for her because she gets it
she gets it more than certainly the
experts and the experts know how to use
the masks to wield political power but
she gets it
much better than any of the
conservatives who went along with this
the masks have always been a terrible
idea
i'm speaking as a political matter right
now because you know you know what
happens
if i were to come onto this show
and say that as a scientific matter the
masks are really a bad idea they're
terrible
big now i'm just speaking hypothetically
here right big tech
would take down this show because big
tech follows the science and the experts
and how dare you michael use your
political judgment
to to describe a scientific matter no
you can't do that you're going to come
down from youtube you're going to come
off of
apple podcasts you're going to leave
spotify you can't
say that you can't question the masks
okay i'll tell you what then
let's have a little experiment on the
show today i have here
from the national institutes of health a
peer-reviewed
scientific study from medical hypotheses
this was published online november 22
of 2020 this was published in the
journal itself
january 2021
this is uh from baruch
vine shell boeing who had been
affiliated he was a fellow i believe at
uh stanford university
he has published the headline face masks
in the kovit 19 era a health hypothesis
i'm just i'm just reading from the
peer-reviewed scientific study on nih
if you take me down for this big tech i
think
that i think the mask has fallen off
many countries across the globe utilized
medical and non-medical face masks as
non-pharmaceutical intervention for
reducing the transmission
and infectivity of coronavirus disease
2019.
although scientific evidence supporting
face masks efficacy is lacking
adverse physiological psychological and
health effects
are established that's from the abstract
of the paper the current article reviews
the scientific evidences with respect to
safety and efficacy of wearing face
masks describing the physiological and
psychological effects
and the potential long-term consequences
on health
it is not clear however what the
scientific and clinical basis for
wearing face masks
as protective strategy given the fact
that face masks
restrict breathing causing hypoxemia
and hypercapnia and increase the risk
for respiratory complications
self-contamination and
exacerbation of existing chronic
conditions data from hospitalized
patients with kovid 19
and general public indicate that the
majority of desks deaths were among
older and chronically ill individuals
supporting the possibility that the
virus
may exacerbate existing conditions but
rarely causes death
by itself here we go here we go say
goodbye because they're about to take me
off
john just quoting from the peer-reviewed
scientific study wearing
face masks has adverse physiological
and psychological effects long-term
consequences of wearing face masks on
health
are detrimental that
from the hypothesis of the paper love
following the science now you know
i don't think our politics should be
based primarily
on the science i think it should be
based primarily on
the politics and the philosophy and the
eternal questions
and our right of self-government and i
don't think that we should outsource
our government to egghead experts
however
even by that premise of the left that
every time we get we find one scientific
paper in the journal especially the nih
putting it out there then we need to do
whatever that says okay well there we go
follow the science and take off the
stupid face masks hey hold up a second
there
if by some chance we are still on
youtube even after reading this study
from the nih describing how dumb
and bad the masks are then you should
make sure you
smash that button subscribe like make
sure that you get more of these videos
because i think youtube doesn't
necessarily
want to promote them all the time so
make sure that you do not miss
a video